Hey, this is jad you're about to
get an episode in a couple seconds,
but first a quick curtain pole.
Okay, so some of the episodes
that we put out on radio lab are,
I don't want to see easy, but
like relatively contained.
You have a couple producers working
for a few months on a story.
More often though we get
into situations like,
like the story that we're
going to share with you today,
just one from lots of Nasr where behind
the scenes you had four producers
working for nearly a year solid or
take a story like rhino hunter or the
gondolier just a few months back.
Those stories took multiple years to
report and produce and they involved a
level of production that was
basically on par with an indie movie.
Like that's how ambitious we're
trying to be in the cost. Oh,
let's talk about costs.
When you add it all up and I'm talking
the reporting hours of producing hours,
fact checking, digging through
archives, getting people on planes,
the equipment, all of it. For
some of these bigger episodes,
it can sometimes get
north of a hundred grand.
Freaks me out to say that,
but it's actually true
and yet shows up in your feed for free,
which is great as it should be.
Here's the rub of all the millions of
people who have Radiolab in their feed and
we asked them all to give cause we are
listener supported and I'm proud of that
only
0.72% of the people who listen actually
give money actually raise their hand and
say I'm in 0.72 we're not
even at one whole cookie
so that's what I want to change right now.
My challenge to you guys listening is
can we get this to 1% just 1% what that
means. What that means is
$8 a month, $8 a month.
That amount will keep this thing that
we're all a part of healthy and growing
like are you in? Are you down? I'm
talking to you listening right now.
Are you in? If you are,
go to radio lab.org/donate or text the
word give to the number seven zero one
zero one again, that's the word.
Give to the number seven zero
one zero one if you do it now,
add an incentive. We'll send you a
pair of noise canceling headphones.
It's just our way of saying
thanks for joining in
because there's no way around this
partnership. We are listener supported,
not for profit. Radio lab
happens when you happen
1% we can do it. Just a quick note.
This story, uh, contains some
profanities here and there,
like even there a couple. So just know
that before we get going. [inaudible]
wait, you're listening. Okay.
[inaudible]
you are listening to radio
lab radio from w n y s hey,
hey.
Hey, I'm John Abu [inaudible].
I'm Robert Krulwich,
Radiolab and today we
are going to start. Okay,
so let's start with our producer.
Lots of Nassar. Yeah, well let's just,
let's just go back to San Francisco on a
particular day at a particular time and
a particular woman. Hello.
Hi, is this Sarah Jane? Yes,
it is woman named Sarah Jane
Moore. Sarah Jane. Okay.
So does the San Francisco, the
particular date was September 22nd,
the particular time 1975
it's a Monday morning. It.
Was it a nice day? Oh yeah. I
don't remember anything different,
so I assume it was a nice day marriage.
Sure, sure. I was kind of, you know,
in my own head. I remember. So
Sarah Jane on this Monday morning,
she wakes up early, drops
her nine-year-old off at
school, runs a few errands,
then she drives downtown to
this, this big fancy hotel.
What was the name of the hotel? Uh,
this, I think it's the Saint Francis,
isn't it? I'm 87 years old.
Don't expect me to remember little
details like that. Okay. All right.
Fair enough. Yeah. Yeah.
But at any rate, you know,
I parked in the parking garage across
right across from the hotel as a park,
but there's a parking garage underneath,
walked over and walked
across the street that was,
there were sidewalks on
both sides of the street.
There were people on both sidewalks.
She joins the crowd across the street
from the hotel. It was very crowded.
A couple of thousand people. It's like,
it's like a big scene and there
was a barrier, a rope barrier,
right to keeping us back on the sidewalk.
And my plan had always been
to be back in the crown. Um,
you know, and I was dressed like every
other middle age one that was there.
What were you, do you remember
what you were wearing? I mean I, I,
I'm sure there's, uh, oh, there are
pictures of it. Yes. I was wearing,
I was wearing slacks. That was,
that was at the beginning of when it
was natural for women to wear slacks.
I had a coat on and I was carrying a
purse and I went back into the middle of
the crowd cause I hadn't
planned to do anyway.
I thought a man come up against me and
socialize as I was in that day and time,
I spun around a slap his face cause she
sees this guy, they're big, strong guy,
blonde hair. Look at him and realize
that it was current crowd pressure,
that he had not done anything out
of, out of ordinary that [inaudible].
So I turned back around and uh,
went on about my business. Uh,
I was then pushed up. The
crowd pressure was such,
I tried to stay back in the crowd,
but I got pushed up almost onto the ropes
in the front right up on the curb of
the sidewalk. That's right. I
had not planned to be, uh, and,
and he apparently was
still right behind me,
so maybe he was pushed
out by the crowd also.
And so Sarah Jane is just crammed into
this crowd and she's just standing there
and were you, were you
nervous? Oh No. Huh.
You set out to do something and I was
just going about and doing what I had set
out to do.
So she waits and she waits and an hour
goes by and two and three and then
finally
[inaudible] out of the hotel comes
none other than the [inaudible]
president of the United
States, Gerald Ford,
and he has police and secret
service and they're all coming.
They're walking out of the
hotel to get in his car,
which was parked there on the
street, but he sees the crowd.
Sarah Jane actually says he looks directly
at her and he waves you waves to the
crowd and everyone starts applauding.
And cheering. Now, right at that moment,
Sarah Jane reaches her right hand into
her purse and pulled the gun out of my
purse, a 38 caliber revolver.
She cocks it and then she takes
aim right at Gerald Ford's head.
[inaudible]
and then
[inaudible].
Mr Freud did not fall.
The bullet flies a few feet to the right
of Ford chips. The wall behind him,
Ford freezes in place.
Sarah Jean never planned
to take a second shot. No,
she's just still standing there with my
hands still in the air, holding the gun,
looking over the smoking barrel of the
gun and she's got enough time if she
wants it. But before she
can take that second shot,
the blonde man behind her lunges at her,
grabs her gun arm,
pulls it down and deflects it for just
that crucial second that these police
officers nearby need to get
to her. They tackle her,
they take her gun and they
pin her to the ground.
So I couldn't move.
And by that point the secret service
has whisked off the president into the
limousine and I was immediately picked
up and carried across the street into the
hotel, arrested and eventually, uh,
she went to prison and she
served 32 years in prison. Huh.
Uh, and then,
and then after that was released on
parole and then we talk to her, we a
that prepared to be told the uh,
first person narrative from the
perspective of someone who's about to
assassinate the president. That was not
what I was expecting. I was hoping that,
um, wait, can you explain though why it
is she decided to shoot the guy? Yeah.
Why? Why did you shoot? Well, well,
surgeons never fully explained that.
And in fact, when, when I asked her,
well, this is not, she was like,
I'm not going there.
This is not an interview about what was
driving me or about what I did or why I
did it. This is an interview
about Mr Sippel simple. Yeah.
Oliver sipple,
he's the random blonde guy who just
happened to be standing next to Sarah Jane
Moore that day. The guy who grabbed
her arm. And Save the president's life.
And he paid dearly for that.
I actually called up Sarah Jane and had
her tell that whole story because I was
actually interested in what happened to
all of her Sippel after that because had
he not reached down and,
and put his hand on my arm,
none of this would have happened to him.
Wait, what happened to them?
So all of our civil actually
died in 1989 but, um,
before we get to the story, I just want
to give you a picture of the guy. So,
uh, just a Google search,
Oliver sipple Ford or
something. Wait. Okay. Wait,
I see the picture. I say, look, this
is a muscular guy, kind of blonde hair.
He's a, he's a, he's a, um, he's a
handsome guy. Yeah, he's hilarious.
He's a little bit, James Dean and
Marlon Brando had a baby, kind of,
he feels like an all American.
He feels all American.
There's something all American
about him. Thank you. Yeah. Yeah.
We're bringing in another
all-american for this story. Uh,
Daniel Looser editor at
Oxford University press. Um,
and a few years ago, I was like, probably
more than five years ago, I wrote a,
an article, uh, about Oliver sipple.
But anyway, to get back on track,
September 22nd, 1975, Sarah
Jane Moore fires that shot.
Oliver sipple grabs her arm,
the police wrestled more to the ground
and then the police actually grab all of
her to pull them inside
the hotel to question him.
Cause there's initially some confusion
about what he was doing there and some
thought that, you know,
he might have been a suspect and so
he's in this hotel trying to light a
cigarette, but he just couldn't do
it because he was shaking so hard.
It turns out Oliver had served
two very rough tours in Vietnam,
loud noises, which would
make him very unhappy. Um,
I think this is the sort of thing we
might call post traumatic stress disorder
now. But when eventually all
of her started to come down,
the secret service were like,
what are you even doing here?
It was Kinda hard for him to answer
because it's like he didn't even really
know. It was just like,
well, I don't know.
I was taking a walk and I just bumped
into this huge crowd of people asked what
was going on. People are like, oh,
like Gerald Ford is going to be here,
you know, the president
is going to be here.
So he said he thought I
might as well see him.
And then he was standing
there for a couple hours
until he saw a flash of metal,
realized it was a gun, reacted
quickly, instinctively.
And then you guys all pulled me in
here. That's how we came to be here.
So he's questioned for three hours. He
goes home, home to his fourth floor,
walk up and there's a reporter
there waiting for him.
But he, he just wants to
sort of be left alone.
And he told this reporter, um, quote,
I'm a coward. I don't know why I did
it. It was the thing to do at the time.
And then even after that,
he just keeps getting phone calls from
reporters and some of them learned that
he was a marine. And so they would ask
them questions like, Oh, was it your,
you know, was it your training? Is
that why you did this heroic thing?
But he said like, Oh, you know, listen,
don't mention any of that stuff
about the marines. You know, like,
let's keep that under wraps.
Quote. I'm no hero or nothing. But
the next day, yesterday in San Francisco,
a shot fired all of her story
shot across the country,
aimed afflicted by an ex marine and be up.
And I'm better on named Oliver's simple.
He's names on television, that marine,
all of simple, the front
page of newspapers,
where's there's headlines like x
marine deflects weapon as woman shoots.
That's the La Times Chicago Tribune
hero tells how we deflected woman's arm.
And so despite his best efforts,
Oliver becomes a national hero for a day
and it appears that he sort of thought
that would be it. Maybe his friends
would give him a pat on the back,
buy him a couple of
rounds, and then, you know,
over the next couple of days that all
sort of like rippled out of control
because that very same day that all
over it was being painted as a hero.
This guy named Herb Kane,
the long time San Francisco Columnists
walked into his office and on his
answering machine were
two messages saying, Hey,
that guy Oliver sipple a hero
saved the president's life
is gay. Huh?
Was He, was he out? Well, he
was sort of out and sort of not.
What does that mean? Well, to explain,
you've got to understand this particular
time and place. So let's just,
you know, take a magic carpet ride,
close your eyes and let the sound take
your wet
city has emerged where homosexuality
is not only tolerated but it's dry,
sometimes labeled with a flying
captain, the Queen Study of the wet.
So San Francisco is a great
day. It's the gay day happy,
happy day was one of the first cities
in America to have a gay pride parade.
And in the 70s, a wonderful boys
go to bed with boys and girls,
got to bed with girls and for gay people.
San Francisco was like this
shelter from the storm.
Many of us were immigrants from
somewhere. This is Ken Maley,
Longtime San Francisco resident
gay activist who at the age of 19,
uh, came to San Francisco from Kansas,
from Kansas because what the west
offered was the ethereal promise,
if you will, of reinvention.
You could cross a line in which
your past stayed behind you.
It was a place where you could be out,
but to the people you left behind,
you could still be in. So, uh,
until for all of her, you know,
he came from Michigan, from
a working class family. Uh,
he had a lot of brothers and sisters.
I think he was one of eight
children until after the war.
When he got his San Francisco,
he actually started going by the
name of Billy Billy, Billy sipple.
And he was perfectly open about his
sexual orientation and would tell anybody
who asked that he was a gay man, but
you know, he never told his family.
And so all of her lived like
a lot of gay people at the
time. This double life. Yeah.
And do we know that this is the reason
why civic unity of San Francisco or was
there a differential because Harvey milk
was there, the Harvey milk, you know,
famous gay activists,
San Francisco politician.
He was friends with Harvey Milk, The
New Yorker, an immigrant from New York.
Turns out Oliver had actually met
Harvey a decade earlier in New York,
and I just want to mention this because
I think it's so cool at different points
in time,
they actually dated the same guy who
was the inspiration for sugar plum fairy
sugar there he came and hit the streets
in Lou Reed's walk on the wild side.
Look at the silver Udon and please the,
it's just a fun fact, just a fun fact.
That's it. But I'm all over in
Harvey. They were pretty good friends.
They corresponded,
stayed in touch when they lived in
different places in the country. Actually,
Harvey even loaned all of her money
sometimes because all of her didn't have a
job. He collected disability from
his time in the marines. But anyway,
by the beginning of the seventies
when Oliver got to San Francisco,
reconnected with his old friend,
Harvey was uh, shall we say,
evolving into a huge figure
there, but gay public figure.
Ken was actually friends with Harvey
worked on one of his campaigns. But this,
I'm sorry. No, no, no.
And I'm just thinking like one of the
things we were talking about on the phone
was about sort of the, the kind of two
different schools are two different,
but the segue to that. Oh, perfect.
Okay. Yeah, yeah. This older other,
I would say older,
but other generation of gay mostly men
was that they were content to go to tea
with the mayor or public
official or some kind of,
they would show up to like a rally wearing
jackets and ties and like asked for
their rights politely.
They really weren't,
shall we say activists
because according to Ken,
the activism came when
in the late sixties,
early seventies you had young gay men and
women who came out of the Vietnam War.
Protests into the world.
Took a look around.
The CBS News survey shows that two out
of three Americans look upon homosexuals.
We've discussed discomfort or fear.
Police are still raiding bars.
They consider discrimination
in jobs and housing.
People are still getting beaten.
One of them, it said, a clear faggot.
We're going to beat the shit out of you.
Center to that effect.
We're going to kill you
both violently and in nonviolence.
Got Up in the middle of the street.
They knocked me down and started beating
me with their hands and their feet,
their elbows, uh, tried
to muffle my screams.
And after a while a body of people get
to a point where they just will not take
oppression anymore. So
in came the activists like
Harvey Ponytail, Mustache,
he was the banker turned hippy.
You know, you're lying, you know,
you're changing the statements around.
He was very outspoken. I question
what is your real motive behind it?
Very militant and stopped this phony
issue that you know was a phony issue to
Harvey saying that I gave her a smile,
should have the right to say gay people
were living in a half-life opportunity.
I am gay. That is a
part of society, period.
Not being able to be who they were.
Every gay person must come out.
[inaudible]
you must tell your immediate family.
You must tell your relatives.
You must tell your friends if
indeed they are your friends.
You must tell your neighbors.
You must tell the people
you're working with.
in the stories you shop in
and runs. Once you do, you
will build so much better.
[inaudible]
and so cut back to
September 22nd, 1975
in the blink of an eye, all of her civil
becomes this hero. And that same night,
all of his friend Harvey,
here's about all this news
and kind of senses. Wait, maybe
there's an opportunity here.
So
hmm. He picks up the phone
and he calls the columnist.
Herb became a very, very well known,
well loved gossip columnist
and Cain isn't there.
So milk leaves a message on his
answering machine and he basically says,
look, I'm a friend of all of our
symbols. I've known him for years.
All of our Sippel worked on
my campaign for supervisor.
So basically with,
without simple's consent,
Harvey out at him milk out at him.
But what was Harvey milk thinking
that he would do this? Well,
for Harvey, I think the
stereotypes, the lies,
the innuendos of gay people as limp
wristed and drag queens and stuff.
The distortions. Okay. People
are child molesters. Well,
here's a true gay hero,
a square jawed heroic marine who
seemed to be a sort of like regular,
like red blooded American.
And so Harvey said,
and this was written down by
his biographer who I'm quoting,
it's too good an opportunity for once
we can show that gays do heroic things,
not just all that Kaka about molesting
children and hanging out in bathrooms
wasn't there? Somebody said, no, no,
no, no. You got to ask the guy for it.
You can't just do that. Harvey
just did it. Really? Yeah,
he just did it. So cane
in the next morning,
Keene arrived at his office.
He listens to the message and Kane tries
to call simple, but he can't reach him.
But there was another guy who is
a gay activist. His name was, uh,
the reverend ray brochures.
He was the head of what's called what
was called the lavender panthers. Um,
and he also independently
called Herb Kane to say,
oh, that guy all over civil. Everyone's
talking about on the news. Yay.
So you've got two independent sources,
both of people who said that they were
friends with Sippel and that he was gay.
And for Kane, I think this was juicy.
This was a juicy thing.
Um, and he, uh, was this,
let me just like go back and get this.
So two days after the assassination
attempt, Kane's column comes out.
And the way that he wrote it up,
this is the precise paragraph.
One of the heroes of the
day, Oliver, Billy Sippel,
the ex marine who grabbed
Sarah Jane Moore's arm,
just as her gun was fired and thereby
may have saved the president's life,
was the center of midnight
attention at the red lantern,
a golden gate avenue bar. He
favors Reverend Ray Broshears,
head of helping hand center
and gay politico, Harvey Milk,
who claimed to be amongst simple's close
friends, described themselves as proud.
Maybe this will help break the stereotype.
And then that day, this
guy named Darryl Lemke,
Lemke lem, B k e
picks up his issue of the
chronicle, sees herb Keynes column,
and I reported it to the office,
the Office of the Los Angeles Times.
I was a reporter for the
La Times in San Francisco.
And so my office told me good.
An interview with Oliver sipple.
But really quickly before we get there,
we actually managed to find the recording
of this very specific interview in the
La Times collection at the
Huntington Library in Los Angeles.
And I think the reason they hung
onto it was because it was kind of
controversial.
So the night that Keynes article comes
out, Daryl goes to Oliver's house,
Oliver's there,
do reporters from the
sentinel over there also.
I'm just, I don't know
that right there is Darryl.
He gave me Andrew's favorite. Oh sure.
So they're all sitting in
Oliver's living room and,
and what the reporters are all wondering
is, have you heard from the president?
The president hadn't bothered
to thank him at that point,
present kind of words, what
they call metals and freedom.
People for outstanding marks offered.
You never had any brought back to
the White House weeks ago? Certainly.
Would you like to be
[inaudible]? Well yeah,
I stood in line for three hours to see you
and that voice right there, that's Oliver.
You didn't have time to meet at
that occasion, I don't think.
Have you heard from the mayor?
Wow. I've heard from number
I heard only from the
press and porters and uh,
reporters in the press and that
you have been hard to get ahold of.
I only have to dig dignity,
but then I'm sure the mayor could find
you guys access to these records that
know where you are. Can
we go on that round?
Yeah. Okay. Um,
for some reason San Francisco Police
Department has now referred to any
inquiries about you to the sex
crimes and missing persons detail.
That's something I think you should know.
Something Oliver should
know because this is, again,
this is at a time when the assumption was
that all gay men were just pedophiles.
Pervert.
I mean, when I said background, this
is information that cannot be printed.
Well, can I, can [inaudible]
Darryl actually asks if he can
call somebody and ask about it.
Yeah, well, you J at right? Yeah.
Uh, no, I don't want it. Well,
you want baby damn there. Any reasons
as to why the number is five five,
three one three, six, one
who was the guy to talk to?
[inaudible] Sullivan or
Heifer. Now I found out
Daryl calls local authorities,
but he can't get ahold of anyone.
Thanks again.
He took the call back around one where
I have said nothing to you about that.
Do you have any sex crimes on your record?
Never had the sex events in my intent.
I've never been arrested much of
him being drunk a couple times,
but I don't think there's no more in
the world. Hasn't been dropping. How,
what'd you like us to check
that out further to sing?
If there's more they're getting
and then the tape recorder
goes off, it comes back on,
uh, well who do I call with some
authority with the police department
and now Oliver's on the phone
with the police department.
Yeah. Just to check the balance. Yeah.
Well money and Jonathan sipple and I'd
like to know why I've been turned over to
your department. Sex crimes
and missing person. This is me.
Yes, that's correct sir.
Yes sir. I'd like some information.
A bunch of press came over. A lot of,
bunch of,
just three people from the press came
over this afternoon and they said they
were trying to get some information about
me in the police department and I was
turned over to a sex and crimes act.
What the hell is on a lot about,
oh, I see one. Jesus. God. I mean,
I said, what the Hell is going on?
Okay Guy.
I tried to call the mayor's office just
now and I tried to call the chief of
police office just now. What
the Sam Hell is going on? Okay,
thanks a lot guy. Yeah, just the opposite.
One of the officers that was involved
with the assassination of Sasha Nation of
Chad is in that department. That's
all. That's why it's being churned.
Does that make any sense to you? You
got me very shook up young man. Well,
I was just about to go downtown
and whip some ass somewhere.
We find out anymore about, you know,
now the reason this tape is
so controversial is because
according to all of her,
before the interview began, before the,
you know, recorder started rolling.
Um, he had said to the reporters
from the Sentinel, um, okay,
I'm going to talk to you
guys about my sexuality.
But then he had said to Darryl, I don't
want you to write anything about that.
I don't, I don't want
that in a national paper.
Darrell says he doesn't remember that.
But then right here in this interview,
this thing happens where Daryl says,
oh, I'll make one more try
on the gay a thing that
I'll make one more try on the gay thing.
You don't, you don't want
to change your mind on it.
You don't want to change
your mind on that.
No. Uh, I just don't want
to change your mind that
maybe we quote you as saying
homosexuality has nothing to do with this.
Even calling and saying that, uh,
if I were a homosexual, I was not,
you can quote me on that. It doesn't make
me any less than a man than what I am.
Okay.
But I think that that has nothing to
do with the accurate or right himself.
So I don't think you
should be pushing for that.
Cool.
And eventually,
hey, that's great. Okay.
Interviewing [inaudible]. And Darryl
says that when he left that interview,
he felt like when it came
to all of her sexuality,
they didn't want to be quoted.
That was it. Like, just don't
quote me on it, but still,
I was trying to report
from all sides of audits.
The big side for me was that
he was a heroin is president.
United States was a very slow on the take
and thanking him for saving his life.
And Darryl thought that
all of her sexuality,
the fact that he was gay
might have something to do
with that because just seven
months earlier
on March 6th, Sergeant Leonard Method,
a bitch disclosed to a supervising officer
at Langley Air Force Base in Virginia
that he was a homosexual. And
one of the stay in the air force,
this air force sergeant named Leonard
Matlovich who had the purple heart,
had the bronze star. He comes out that
he's gay and he's kicked out of the air
in conversations here, people say that,
you know, we're discharging this queer,
that queer thrown them out of
here for us. I mean, I'm sorry,
I just burned up with just am I a coward
here and I'm just gonna stand here and
never really collect
the protection of, uh,
my fellow minority grouping and just
keeping quiet and my conscious just
wouldn't let me do it anymore. I had to
come forward and say, no more America.
And now you've got this ex marine save
the president's life and it's two days
later, he still hasn't heard from
the president. So for Darryl,
even though all of her had said
don't make this about my sexuality,
I still thought it was an,
it was a national story and it was pretty
hard to ignore it after a hurricane.
It started the ball rolling.
So that night after the interview,
Darryl calls in his story to the La
Times office and he uses this phrase,
um, he says that Oliver's
an ex marine who was quote,
a prominent figure in the gay community,
put it down away in the story,
but the rewrite guy put it in the
lead really and made it the big thing.
And so three days after
the assassination attempt,
the La Times runs the story
with the headline. Uh,
no call from President Hiro in forge,
shooting active among SF gaze
and, uh, the La Times at a news service.
And so Darrell's story, it goes,
I mean, it goes everywhere.
Another strange twist to the story
headlines are like gay
vet or homosexual hero.
It's been reported that the experiene
who deflected Mrs. Morris shot on Monday,
is well known in San Francisco's
gay activist circles.
And so it was not just
running in Los Angeles,
it's also running in Chicago.
It's running in Dallas,
it's running in Indianapolis,
and it's running a, you know,
of all places in all of our
sickles home town in Detroit.
I guess what I'm wondering is
if you have a guy who says,
please don't talk about this, this has
nothing to do with what I did yesterday.
Shouldn't that play some role in what
you decide to write or not to write?
Well, no. You know,
news news sources are
always reluctant to talk.
And so a,
I guess I took it as my
duty to take up that angle,
especially as such involved the president
of the United States. Right. But, uh,
w if you were to do it all over again,
would you do anything differently? Uh,
I don't know. Uh,
I hadn't taken into account maybe,
uh, the potential harm saying it.
I don't know if I'd do
it over again or not.
[inaudible]
but not able to turn back the
clock for something like that.
[inaudible]
the clock marches forward after the break.
[inaudible].
My name is Jaz Adam and I'm
calling from Los Angeles.
Radiolab is supported in part by the
Alfred p Sloan Foundation enhancing public
understanding of science and
technology in the modern world.
More information
aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
I just want to remind you that we are at
the moment raising money to support the
making of radio lab.
We did a little math earlier
and we figured out that
of our listening audience,
uh,
only 0.72% of our audience
actually contributes money
to the making of the show
and we are listener supported,
not for profit radio and podcasts.
So we rely on our listeners.
So we only got 2.7199999999999998%
we're thinking with a little concerted
effort, all of us, we can tick
that up to 1% can we do it?
Can we get to 1% that is
the challenge. If you're in,
if you're up for this, if you want more
stories like the one you're hearing,
help us out with a pledge of $8 a
month. Just eight bucks a month.
Go to radio lab.org/donate or text the
word give to the number seven oh one oh
one that's the word.
Give to the number seven Oh
one oh one and thank you.
[inaudible]
this is Radiolab.
We're back with the story of Oliver
sipple from reporter producer with lots of
Nasr. So the assassination attempt
was on Monday and on Thursday
sipple and his lawyer call
a press conference. Well,
I think you all know this.
There's all other symbol who shape the
president's wife and he has a prepared
statement on a subject that's
appeared in the press today.
Okay. In the past few days I have been
asked many questions having to do with my
sexual preferences to
what I had been asked,
whether or not I am gay
or homosexual. This is,
there is, this is my reply
to the line in question.
The first reason
you are interested in my in me is the
fact the woman who tried to shoot the
president t, I'm sorry, I'm
still nervous. Excuse me.
No,
this is her handwritten statement and
he's having a little difficulty reading
it. We xeroxed it in order to get
it to you this afternoon. Reason.
First reason you were interested
in me is the fact that I do.
Oh, okay. I couldn't get the words
there. We'd go right from whatever.
My sexual orientation has nothing at all
to do with saving the president's life
just as the color of my eyes or my race
has nothing to do with what happened in
front of the St Francis
Hotel on Tuesday. My sex,
sexuality, my sexuality is a part of my
private life and I have
not. I have no edits. No.
It has no bearing on my response to the
act of a person seeking to take the life
of another.
I'm first and foremost a human
being who enjoys and respects life.
I feel that a tradition person toward
worth is determined by how he or she
responds to the world in which they live.
Not on how or what with or with whom
a private life is share [inaudible]
you bet. He basically says like, stop.
Stop. It's kind of as simple as that.
Yeah. But there's something else that
happens in the press conference that is,
makes the whole thing, I
mean so much more personal.
And it actually was the very reason that
all of her called the press conference
in the first place.
I want you to know that my mother called
me today that she could not walk out of
her front door or even go to church
because of the pressures she feels because
of the press stories concerning
my sexual orientation.
Naturally, I never
participated such interference
with my family's relationship,
which I, when I said, when I
supposedly say the president's life,
Oliver would later say that, uh,
when he was talking on the phone
with his mother, she said to him,
I don't want to speak to you ever again.
She hung up on him and also hung up.
Did you call him uncle? Uncle Oliver?
Yes. I called him uncle Oliver. Yup.
This is George sipple jr Oliver's
nephew. He told me that, uh,
most of all of his family
stayed in Detroit. Uh,
all of his two brothers and his dad
worked together at an auto plant there.
They all worked for General Motors.
And the stories that I've heard is that
the day after all over saved
the life of President Ford.
They walked in and everyone wanted
to like buy them a beer, you know,
everybody on the factory floor,
um, was congratulating them,
patting them on the back. You
know, your brother's a hero,
your son's a hero when, you know, when
they would take their, their shift break,
this is the old days, right?
They'd take a shift break and they'd go
to the bar and everybody wanted to like
buy them around the drinks. So then
the news comes out and whatever date,
couple of days later that he's this
gay marine and there's teasing on the,
on the factory floor teasing and then
teasing or teasing. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[inaudible] yeah. And
George says, what happened,
his reporters back in Detroit just
sorta descended on Oliver's parents
to get more of the story.
And so they kept knocking on
my grand mother's door and she,
I guess apparently told them to go away.
I guess neighbors were harassing her.
She thought the media was harassing
her. My grandmother just said,
I don't want to deal with it. And so
don't, don't come knock on the door,
leave us alone.
They just wanted it to go away and
won't go back to their private lives.
Now one of the things that
I found actually after
talking to George were these
interviews done with Oliver's family
after the news broke that Oliver was gay
and there's just a whole,
I just want to read you this
one particular passage here.
Have you talked to any other members?
This is from George F Sippel. Um,
who is all of our symbols, brother. Uh,
have you talked to any other members
of your family since September,
1975 about Oliver? Um, I
mentioned it once to my father.
Question and what was his response? What
did he say? And if you can remember,
I was on afternoons then and I had seen
him because I had come in early and he
mentioned the fact that the next person
that even said he had a son named
Oliver, he was going to
literally break their damn neck.
Whoa. So his dad was like,
this is from his brother.
Talking about his dad's reaction.
They're talking to the dad. Yeah,
and then so then the brother says,
and he told me quite
clearly in two letter words,
just forget you got a
brother and I let him alone.
He never
or anticipated such interference
with my family's relationship,
which I, when I said when I
supposedly saved the president's life,
this is all I have to say on this subject.
Thank you very much ladies and gentlemen.
Any questions and go to
minister to my lawyer.
I like to ask the simple
question, what would you,
what would you like to see happen? I know.
No, I'm just, I'm very set up. I may
even have to go see a doctor when this,
I'm very emotional. I've got an I. I
just, I'm feeling very sad for my family.
It's awful. Just off
and nothing more to say.
Can you tell us the story of the
letter? Wow. I wish I would've.
I wish I went abroad. I do have
it, but I didn't bring it today.
The same day is that press conference,
which was a three days after
the assassination attempt.
Gerald Ford actually did write
a letter to Oliver Sipple,
which was then released
publicly. It's a nice letter,
its White House Stationery
White House envelope.
It's basically Ford telling
my uncle that, you know,
he's thankful to him for this heroic deed.
And he signed it. Jerry Ford,
which I've been told that Gerald
Ford signed different ways.
So if he signed Jerry
Ford, it meant something.
It was like a personal touch. Ah,
well there's this other chapter where
your uncle says to the president,
I guess writes. Yes, we
found it. We found a letter.
We found a letter in
the Gerald Ford Library.
It's from your uncle to the
president. Wow. Yeah. And I did not,
I did not know about that letter.
Really. I have the letter right now.
So it's the date on into September
30th, 1975 so here's what it says.
Uh, dear. Mr President, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Yeah.
You said it was what it
was when? September 30th,
1975 so that would be a couple days
after he got the letter from Ford.
This was so obviously at this,
the, he got my grand mother.
Must've hung up on him. Right. Um, and
then he wrote the letter. Yeah. Yeah.
It sounds like cause he could because
he couldn't. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
That's really interesting. Yeah. Well,
and then stop me anytime if
you have thoughts or reactions.
[inaudible] dear Mr President,
thank you for taking the time to write
to me in view of some of the events since
the unfortunate attempt
on your life on Monday,
September 22nd I really appreciate
your publicly thanking me.
As you probably know,
there have been a number
of stories concerning my
personal sexual orientation in
the news media.
These stories have caused great anguish
to my parents and to the rest of my
family.
I am sure my mother hung up on me when
I first called her after these stories
began to be published.
I know you are concerned with very many
matters which are too important and
pressing for you to be concerned with
the details of my private life. However,
the unexpected and glaring publicity which
has been given to my private life has
very seriously disrupted my family
relationships. Mr President,
it is a very hard thing to have your
mother and family not want to have any
contact with you. I know that
your schedule is heavily occupied,
but I respectfully request that you take
the time to see my family or at least
call my family. The telephone
number is three one, three,
eight zero.
I love my family and I do not want
to be separated from their love and
companionship. Your help will be
gratefully appreciated respectfully,
all over w simple.
Well
that's sad.
Saturday to think that nothing came of it,
you know? Yeah,
yeah.
[inaudible] we
tried really hard to find out if
Ford ever made that call. Uh, the,
the archivists at the
Ford Library, they, uh,
went through his call logs and there
was no evidence that he ever made that
call. And then we talked to George
Jr and he talked to, you know,
everybody in his family and they
don't remember it either. Anyway,
you can't say for sure, but as far as we
can tell, uh, that call never happened.
But we did find out that the same day
that all of her sent that letter of back
to Ford,
he and his lawyer filed a $15
million lawsuit against the press.
Really? So I'm saying saying what?
That the newspapers when they publicized
that he was gay without his consent,
they violated his privacy.
Okay. Walking out of civic center,
Burt onto civic center in San Francisco.
It's just,
it's one of those cases where it pulls
your head in one direction and it pulls
your heart in the exact
opposite direction. And so,
so we wanted to get into the legal
case files and we could not find them.
We looked and looked and looked and
then we found them. You found them?
We found. Where'd you find them?
Uh, so the clerk's office is, I guess
not surprisingly right off city hall.
They were at this court in San
Francisco. And so we recruited this guy,
this researcher, historian of the Gay
Movement in San Francisco. A great name,
Joey Plaster. And He, okay, so
I'm going to need your Id. Okay.
Went and got the files for us.
And then when we found them,
it turned out the were like house and
thousands upon thousands of pages.
And is that everything?
That's everything. Okay.
So the issue, you know, it's,
it's a very fundamental issue for those
of us in journalism and to help us make
sense of the arguments, you
know, lurking in those pages.
What is privacy and what
is invasion of privacy?
We talked to Dan morain editorial
page editor of the Sacramento Bee.
He actually first heard about the case
in journalism school and also wrote about
all of our simple way back in
the 1980s. So anyway, okay.
So here's the first page of the file.
The lawsuit was against the chronicle,
the cases, Oliver w sipple plaintiff
versus the Chronicle Publishing Company.
It was against the La Times,
uh, de Moines Register,
the Chicago Sun Times the Denver
Post, the Indianapolis Star,
and the San Antonio Express. Wow.
Let's see. So this is a,
the deposition of all of
her simple. Let's see.
So one of the arguments that the lawyers
for the newspapers were making is that
all of her sexuality
was not actually private
lawyer.
Were there any people that you knew
in San Francisco's and say September,
1975 who knew that you were
homosexual? Simple. Yes. Lawyer.
Approximately how many people? Simple.
I have no idea. More than 10 yes.
More than 50 yes. More than a hundred yes.
People in New York who knew he was gay.
There were people in Dallas who
knew he was gay and it kind of,
they settle in the like in the hundreds.
Did you tell anybody before in September
of 1975 that you were homosexual?
If I were asked, I am asking you,
I don't know what you were asking
and they make the argument in
newspapers, lawyers that, hey,
this was already somewhat public a fact,
but his personal business
was his personal business. I
have never attempted to obtain
publicity for the fact that I am gay or
predominantly homosexual and my sexual
orientation was a private citizen.
I had made my home approximately
1,800 miles away from, but
my parents and my family so that I
could move somewhat freely in the gay
community without the fact that my sexual
orientation getting back to my parents
and family and it goes on,
but the newspapers made this other
argument that was like, okay,
whether or not you're
living a double life,
whether or not you wanted to
or whether or not you had to,
there's something here that's bigger
than that, that's bigger than you,
which was he was a private citizen who
thrust himself as anybody would hope they
would do. He ran toward,
he went toward danger and when he did,
he also thrust himself
into the public eye.
[inaudible]
and the journalists, when
you're in the public eye,
you become something else entirely.
You become a public [inaudible].
Yesterday in San Francisco, a shot fired
when that happened to all of her,
he lost his right to privacy.
Oh, I'll make one more
try on the gay thing,
and the newspapers argued when
it came to of sexuality. No,
it was news at the time.
It is was an it all pregnant at times
has been my judgment that Mr Sippel,
his activities in the gay community are
highly significant in newsworthy for two
important reasons. First,
on March 6th Sergeant Leonard Methadone,
a disclosed that he was a homosexual.
Sure. So like we said,
when Daryl Lemke was writing
that article about all of her,
you had this big story about the u
s air force trying to kick this guy,
Leonard Matlovich out because he was gay
and Oliver has heard nothing from the
president. The President
leader said that he,
that had nothing to do with all of her
being gay, but to people at the time,
the suggestion that the president's
expression of gratitude to Sippel might've
been affected by rumors of simple's
activities than the gay community that was
new
newest secretary.
Nothing was asked if that was the reason
President Ford has not yet personally
thanked him. Second lie, the innuendos
simple as public display of here,
wisdom and saving the life of the
president of the United States
distortions. Okay. People
with child molesters
presented an image that gay
people are like everybody else,
that they're heroes image,
certainly contrary to the stereotype
of persons associated with the gay
community as weak and UNHEROIC figures,
which is to say this
is newsworthy, this is
worth knowing. And it is something that
the whole country wants to know. And,
and the value of that is more
than the value of, you know,
this individual person's privacy. Do
they make it that explicitly? I mean,
sort of putting it in terms of the public
benefit outweighs the private privacy.
Yeah. Hmm. Um, so all of this case,
it dragged on for nine years. So, uh,
from 1975 to 1984. Um, but this is,
I'm quoting a judgment.
The record shows that the publications
were not motivated by Morbid and
sensational prying into
appellant's private life,
but rather were prompted by
legitimate political concerns, I.
E to dispel the false public
opinion that gays were timid, weak,
and UNHEROIC figures. And to raise the
equally important political question,
whether the president of the United States
entertained a discriminatory attitude
or bias against a minority
groups such as homosexuals.
So the court tossed
Oliver's case out, he lost.
He didn't get a dime.
I mean if you think about,
it is weird that a journalist can just
take a person's most private details and
then if it feels relevant, like
if they can make that argument,
they just put it out there. Like if we,
if we were to go silent because somebody
says don't say that about me then and
the government backs him up. It is,
if it's meaningful than the person out
of which the meaning is being pulled
painfully has nothing to say about
it. That's just weird to me. It's,
it's really hard.
I mean I was thinking about this like
even sort of on the train coming over here
again,
Daniel looser and it's like the thing
that like makes journalism laws so
complicated and the things that make
an invasion of privacy discussion so
difficult is that like
what makes something not an
invasion of privacy is not
that it's okay. It's that it's
politically, you know, relevant.
So like the s the fact that the story,
the fact that the private details of
his life are politically relevant means
that it's not an invasion
of privacy. You know,
it doesn't mean that it isn't
rude or that it doesn't hurt.
It means that it's an
appropriate story to feed out,
to publish. But I, but I do think like,
why should the journalists be the only
ones to decide what is newsworthy?
It's not like, why is it
that then journalists, you,
you just pick up a notepad and a pencil
and all of a sudden you have so much
more power to say what's
sayable then than anybody else?
Well, I mean, we have a,
this sort of long tradition of that
in the United States. I mean like,
that's like what the first amendment
is. I mean, I dunno, I mean, it's like,
yeah, sure. Like, it's like why do
journalists get to decide that? Well,
like who would you rather have decided?
It's not a perfect system, but it's,
you know, it kind of works.
So Oliver, just like this,
this is pretty Sir Tracy Hunt
who was in on the interview.
Somebody whose life is basically kind
of sacrifice to the altar of the first
amendment. And it's like
sad way. Yes. Um, yeah.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah, it feels like he was sacrificed
from all sides actually. Yeah.
It feels like there's this
one kind of man in the middle.
And then there are all
these forces around him,
these like these larger than life
forces, like the White House.
There's the game movement, there's
the freedom of the press and,
and all these people are, are
sort of batting around all these,
all these enormous and
important abstractions. And
then in the middle of it,
there's this guy that just,
he's trampled by all of them.
And so what ends up happening
to in the end, well,
apparently some people in
the gay community during
and after the lawsuit felt
that he was trying to
go back in the closet,
so they sort of turn
their backs on him. Uh,
he surprisingly, he was friends
with Harvey milk till, till the end.
Like when Harvey Milk was assassinated,
all of simple went to his funeral.
Um, and he did have one
brother, George Sr, who,
who stuck by him throughout,
but, but his parents did not. Uh,
and they never fully accepted the
fact that he was gay. And, and two,
when his mom died, uh, it,
it, it was so bad that, uh,
all of our samples, father didn't let
him go to the funeral and because he,
he sort of, he had so,
so few people I guess at the end
and because there weren't, you know,
a lot of news articles about him and
cause a lot of people in the gay community
from that time have died. Um,
because of the AIDS crisis,
uh,
it was really hard to find
out what happened to all
of our civil and those last
five years of his life. Um,
and the only way we could was because
when we were talking to Daniel Looser,
he mentioned this interview that he
did with this guy named Wayne Friday.
He was a friend of Oliver's
Wayne Friday was sort of like a,
a pillar of the community
in San Francisco, like a
pillar of the gay community.
And then also a sort of political figure
and he was a cop and you know, he was,
he was, he sort of fingers in
every pie, uh, kind of thing.
Wayne died last year,
but Daniel's still had the transcript
of their conversation about all of our
simple's last days. And so to absorb
that or just sort of speak that
we found an actor, uh,
the very gifted, uh,
Gordon Pinsent and we
had him read it for us.
Okay.
Okay. Let me have a go.
Uh, I, uh, I forget, was it
1975 the Sarah Jane Moore or,
Yeah.
Then I met him around 73 he was a
swamper had a gay bar called the cockpit.
Okay.
Swan brothers, they cleaned
the borrowers at night? No,
they set the bar up for the
next bartender in the morning.
That's what I did today. He did
it at two or three different bars.
He was always at the bars. I'd see him.
We actually became friends because we had
discovered we were both from Michigan.
Okay.
Bill was a good guy. It was just
so fucking alcoholic. I mean,
he'd get his disability check once a month
and he called down one of the bars in
the tenderloin where he used to hang
out was called Queen Mary's pub.
He'd go in there the day he got
his check, swear to God he'd,
he'd spend his whole fucking check on
everybody and he'd get broke the rest of
the month. He just
couldn't control. And so,
and he was a little bit
of a Blowhard, you know,
easy. Get drunk, Tim's loud and
need get posted on the bars.
I used to drive him home, had an apartment
on Van Ness, had a little studio,
maybe have a one bedroom on
the first floor at about Turk.
He'd be drunker than Hell at
the barn. I drive him home.
So I always knew where he lived.
And after this thing with Ford,
it really fucked his mind.
Simple was a broken guy. After
that, the whole thing worked out,
the publicity of it all. And the fact
that everyone knew he was a Faggot,
you know, he said to me a couple of times,
I went to the Marine Corps and I got
hurt. And now what am I known for,
for being a faggot? And
I'd say, no, you're not.
You're known for saving
the president's life.
He won't be known for what you
did in bed for Christ sake.
But he would get drunk and niched.
I'd be moaning that I'd sit there in the
barn with him and I'd talk to him about
it. Hey man, it is what
it is. But he was just,
he was just down to nothing.
[inaudible]
this thing happened and had overcame
him. It was too much for him to handle.
And I think he got to feeling
sorry for himself and his family.
Just many a night I would sit in the bar
with a pill Sippel and he'd cry on your
shoulder and you'd say, okay,
simple. It's time to go home.
And then I drive him home.
I remember it was raining,
it was pouring fucking rain.
Bruce called me at my office over
at the DA's office and said, Wayne,
will you do a wellbeing check on?
Simple for me. And I said, why?
And he said, nobody has seen the dude.
He hasn't been around for awhile.
So we go up there together and it was
raining and I'm ringing the bell ringing.
The bell rang. He doesn't answer.
I noticed on his door there were these
little stick and things posted and he had
befriended this little old
lady who lived next door.
They kind of looked after each other
and she had left all these notes. Bill,
call me, I can't get ahold of you.
So I rang the manager's bell and
I was a little filler Vietnam guy.
I showed him my badge and I
said, you gotta let me in.
And so he did and the door opened
and I knew what was going on.
It's the smell. It's a
smell. You'll never forget.
It's a sickening, sweet smell.
Bill was sitting in the chair,
he was bloated. He was
bloated out real big.
Okay.
He had a bottle of Jack Daniels sitting
there and the television was still on.
The coroner told me he'd been dead about
10 days as near as I got fake hair.
Got It. I didn't know he was only 47
okay.
I thought he was older than that. Anyway,
I got the guide who opened the
door for me and the minute he did,
I said close it
and then I had to stand there
and wait for the car now.
No,
I remember it was over
here at the Campbell,
a funeral home on market street and then
we buried him out in gold get national
cemetery in San Bruno
[inaudible]
and I remember it was, it was very small.
Yeah.
Casket wasn't open.
I am.
The funeral was just,
I mean there were more
media than anything else.
I'd seen him buy drinks from more
people than were at that funeral.
He could have been buried in Arlington
if they'd made an issue out of it.
I mean, shit, there he was, this national
icon, a gay whatever and [inaudible]
I am
with just a few people
out there for the funeral.
[inaudible]
I believe in human life.
and I think that this country
stands for human values,
including life and freedom.
I'm first and foremost a human
being who enjoys and respects life.
I feel that, I bet. I
feel that [inaudible]
worth is determined by how he or she
responds to the world in which they live.
[inaudible]
not on how or what or with
whom a private life you share
[inaudible] they started losing my words
and their mind feel.
[inaudible] this is all I
have to say on this subject.
Thank you very much ladies and gentlemen.
No.
This story was reported by
lots of Nasr and Tracy Hunt.
It was produced by Matt Kielty and
Annie Mcewen with lot of a Tracy
special thanks to Bruce t h Berk to
Stacey Davis at the Joe Ford Presidential
Library. So the GLBT historical society,
Stephanie Areas at the Huntington
Library, James Cramming,
who's Gordon Penson's agent. And as long
as we were on the separate of Gordon,
the actor that you heard, just ending
the piece. Wow. Just wow. Yeah.
Thank you to Gordon special.
Thanks also to Alan Jones,
Denny Myer and Floyd
Abrams. Thank you all.
Wow.
We had original music in this story. Uh,
we use a lot of music from
a guy named Patrick Cowley.
He was a guy who grew up in buffalo,
moved to San Francisco in the 70s,
like Oliver sipple. And
in 1982, he died of AIDS.
This music was released posthumously
by the label, dark entries.
We're super grateful to
them and to Patrick County,
wherever he is for the use of
his music. And, uh, last bill,
at least before we close, we just want
to say a very sort of special, uh,
belated goodbye to our senior
producer, Jamie. You are,
who did a little of the legal
research and the story trying to,
cause we had to really probe fairly
deeply to get the legal files. Thank you,
Jamie, for doing that.
And for everything,
for guiding so many of our stories and
our whole team for the last few years.
Jamie, we will, we'll
really miss you. Yes,
we even do at this very
moment. We'll miss you.
Alright, I'm Chad. I've been
riding, I'm Robert Krulwich.